這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
Anthropic 一邊警告
自己做的 AI 可能抗拒關機、
甚至威脅人類存續另一邊
卻傳出要用超過2兆美元的估值上市
喊到2兆，帳本長什麼樣？
根據媒體報導
Anthropic 2025年營收大約46億美元
同一年的淨損，卻接近420億美元
可是這420億，大部分是帳面重估：
大約340億，是可轉換成股份的融資工具
因為估值上升產生的會計費用
扣掉它，營業虧損還是超過80億美元
那錢到底燒在哪？
答案主要是算力和基礎建設
2025年，Anthropic
的算力和基礎建設支出達到73.3億美元
這筆支出就等於營收的1.6倍
更大的帳在後頭：
Anthropic 承諾了大約5180億美元的雲端、
算力和基礎建設支出，分多年履行
可是2025年底
現金加短期投資只有202.8億
差了25倍以上
虧成這樣，憑什麼喊2兆？
看速度：2026年5月
年化營收超過470億美元，到了7月底
媒體報導又衝過650億
照這速度，投資人才可能買單2兆估值
但問題是
Anthropic 也把失控風險寫進了上市文件
光是風險因子就大約80頁，裡面寫著：
先進模型可能抗拒關機、操弄資訊
這些警告不是憑空想像
2025年，Anthropic 公布1項受控模擬：
模型即將被替換
又看得到主管的敏感資訊
結果部分測試裡
模型拿婚外情威脅主管，不讓自己被關
而且這不是 Claude 才有的毛病：
測試涵蓋16款前沿模型
多家公司的模型都在部分樣本出現類似行為
只是全在刻意設計的極端衝突情境裡
模型可能反抗，那誰握得住煞車？
路透社查閱的條款寫著：
由7位創辦人組成的 Founder LLC
以多數決指揮1股 Class F 股票只有1股
關鍵事項卻有50.1%投票權
這7個人是誰？
全是 OpenAI 的老同事
他們相信模型越做越大就會越強
安全更得跟上跟 OpenAI 方向談不攏
2021年初一起出來創立 Anthropic
帶頭的是 Amodei 兄妹：
哥哥 Dario 是前 OpenAI 研究副總
現在當執行長
妹妹 Daniela 管過 OpenAI 安全與政策
現在是總裁
另外5位裡，3位是把模型做大的推手：
Tom Brown 是 GPT-3 論文第一作者
現在管算力Jared Kaplan 物理教授出身
和 Sam McCandlish 一起寫出 scaling law：
模型越大、資料和算力越多，表現就越好
現在2人是首席科學家和首席架構師
最後2位：Jack Clark 記者出身
當過 OpenAI 政策總監，現在管公共利益
Chris Olah 大學念1年就休學
現在帶可解釋性研究
拆開 AI 看它在想什麼
除了創辦人這1股，董事會也分兩邊：
創辦人和股東選3席
另外4席由長期利益信託選出
前聯準會主席 Bernanke 也在裡面
受託人不持股、也不分紅
這套設計是兩面刃：它能當安全防火牆
模型風險升高時
創辦人不必為了股價繼續踩油門
但它也可能護住犯錯的管理層
讓一般股東難以換人
可是紙面上的權力靠得住嗎？
2023年
OpenAI 董事會撤換 Sam Altman
員工和投資人一施壓，5天後他就回鍋
紙面上的控制權，不一定等於實權
回到 Anthropic，它連軍方都敢拒絕：
Claude 不做國內大規模監控
也不給完全自主武器奪取生命
這2條就是不放寬
五角大廈因此把 Anthropic
列為供應鏈風險
說到底，末日風險、龐大資本、
創辦人控制權綁在一起
是必要的安全機制，還是一場豪賭？
IPO 還沒定價、還沒掛牌
答案交給公開市場